Wow hello [ __ ] him 20 playing yard bird
without a rating what did he do that I
mean I'm kind of down but he sees deep
down the rabbit hole what happened there
okay so got a new zoo here feels like
i've had this ere we had this before and
this is the best line and it is good for
white but i have forgotten the details
so we'll see how this unfolds the
Shekinah probably it's been a while I
studied this just a couple of weeks ago
it and never got it on the board after
after that and then you forget things
now add 96 is kind of very simplistic
probably not the correct
I still 95 s also still very very solid
firm
well okay any witnesses at least talk to
us screw up the White Queen system Ruby
one
hmm why is he trying something else I
don't know be five or something fancier
now Quincy Sam looks very normal
ok this one ok something I had on the
radar am I not just taking stuff now ok
I'll just take stuff ok well he has some
ok yes i see two at the end
takes a 97 on everything gets taken and
Roxy tours is probably coming and then
he will equalize so it's not that great
hmm c1 maybe it's a little bit more
interesting transfer before yeah it's
still very very dry
Harry I should've taken to seven just
keep it simple winning chances are very
slim anyway and I might be maybe I'm
being too ambitious but he cannot do
much Roxy 593 now he had this one who I
would like to go in go for now f3 here
first and then rugby three NT form then
bring the King around King f2 I have to
play anyway so I'm going to do this now
would be three threatening e 40 we form
what's the deal here g5 right it seems
to have a bad day black resigns yeah we
did that rating everybody has their bad
days and this is probably one of
Yardbirds yeah he stumbled right into
that into this thing yeah ok I did not
remember correctly what is correctly I
think we are on a theoretical position
here maybe I can do something better
than 96 I don't know a three or
something I mean this position is super
solid like definitely should equalize as
this b5 looks good you can also check on
v7 now ok here i can take the seven but
I felt that leads ultimately nowhere
right do this this looks it too rookie
7b to RA for is interesting ok I didn't
see that one
yeah this is getting super dangerous ok
so be 485 this yeah yeah I have
definitely a half winning chances so
maybe I should have done that I felt
like it would evaporate them came and
this is probably just equal but I'm
putting I'm asking some questions here
and I don't know and that's not that
easy maybe the engine wants to go d6 now
and this is already a little bit
problematic here here and now he has to
go G for him and it's still ok this is
ok 595 Kim Ji Won Wow hmm I'm sure yeah
this helped tremendously of course I'm
winning a piece or them or the exchange
so a bit sudden this end of this game ok
well guys thanks for watching